so here did you talk about this movie I
loved understatements what can I say
[Music]
parasite
so parasites movie needs no introduction
from me the Oscar wins a parasite it won
Best Original Screenplay bong joon-ho
the director won Best Director won Best
Foreign Language Film and Best Picture
at this point I assume if you watch my
channel you're a movie person you've
probably heard of parasite you're not a
movie person and you watch my channel
Thanks in a world where I have nothing
to offer for this review I have nothing
new to offer for this review there are
YouTube videos breaking down parasites
at nauseam doing the deep dive so really
I can't offer you anything here that you
haven't already heard except for my
personal opinion I guess you haven't
heard that yet that that's the thing in
this video you can't find anywhere else
you can find my face this face
hey you clicked on it parasite is a
South Korean film but what it's about
okay it's like this like I know the
director bong joon-ho I saw him say the
best way to go into this movie is cold
so I'm gonna give you a non spoiler
warning basically I'm gonna do that
first act setup that I do in any review
where it's kind of like oh here's kind
of what the movies about all right cut
off before we start getting into
spoilers and here's what I think about
the movie so out of respect for him and
his work and the fact that he would want
you to go into the movie cold not
knowing anything I'm gonna let you know
alright I'm gonna kind of let you know
where the movie heads if you don't want
to even know that long story short you
should see parasites great but the
movies about this family living in
poverty and the son gets the opportunity
to be an English tutor for this rich
family's daughter and then he's like hey
I know someone who could be an art
instructor for your son and then he kind
of weasels his sister into it the whole
family just kind of weasels their way
into this rich family's house and of
course the rich family doesn't know
they're all related so it's this whole
they're hustlers it's a scheme going on
and that kept the movie really engaging
even intense when there wasn't
necessarily an intense moment but it's
always on your mind like are you guys
but the movie is definitely about
classism and the rich versus the poor
and the way this movie breaks it down
and portrays it's pretty genius I mean
that's not even all there is in the
movie I mean it's about social class
social status this side versus that side
yes but it's not even limited to just
that to the point not to sound redundant
but it's a movie about human beings how
we treat each other versus how we view
each other how we don't even think it's
well here but it does it in a way that's
fun so it's weirdness out loud but the
movie is actually quite fun in its
execution it's funny it's whimsical it's
fun but also turns up the drama it's
relevant it's actually dark
thought-provoking this movie has a scene
that goes from fun to very intense to
pretty dark and tragic not every
filmmaker can pull that off without
having conflicting tone there's a scene
with a storm that wonderfully
illustrates like how the two families
deal with it and what it means to them
and it just it puts it all into
perspective for it's a kid this is
actually a true story I was young I was
no older than 11 or 12 and remember this
girl she was younger she was in the
single digits probably eight or nine so
she's younger than me this is in church
and we were all all these kids were
pumps cuz we were like yeah there might
not be any school tomorrow there's gonna
be snow yeah no school and snow we're
gonna play in the snow is gonna be fun
but I remember her saying it's easy to
say that but what about all the poor and
homeless people and they're gonna freeze
and that's it's easy to see it your way
but what about how they experience it
true story and this is the 90s you know
what's in social media around it it was
like this kid just goes to church anyhow
there's a part in this movie that kind
of illustrates the same thing with
weather and it just took me right back
to that that time when I was a kid that
a younger kid taught me that lesson that
parasite sillas wild world and it's one
of the impressive things about this
movie more than a few times I've seen a
movie have a message but it's like the
movie relies on its message to carry the
entire thing so it's like off the
message doesn't hit you it's what do you
have now what do you have for a movie
what do you have for a film what do you
have for entertainment but this movie if
you want to see the message and you
definitely it's there I mean at a point
you you can't not see it anymore but the
movie itself message aside is remarkably
entertaining it's like a dark drama
comedy it's a dark dramedy more movies
fail at that then succeed at that and
parasites one of the ones that does
succeed in that and astronomy we call
that the Goldilocks zone God
give props to Kang ho song I believe
that's how you pronounce his name might
be a couple of mispronunciations in here
but that dude everyone in the movie does
a great job I thought they were all
fantastic but when I think of the cast
like he's the one who stands out he was
amazing I'm actually really shocked he
wasn't nominated for an Oscar but dude
just crushes it I thought it was great
it's definitely one of those movies you
need to do a second pass like after you
watch it you should probably watch it
again because when you start realizing
how the movies addressing what it's
addressing and how it's breaking it down
cool to go back and watch the movie
again and see how it does it from the
beginning up until the point you
actually kind of it gripped you with an
implication does that mean I watch this
movie twice but yep there's no real rush
to get my review out so yeah I watched
it twice I was glad I watched it twice I
appreciated it more the second time cuz
in the end I thought parasite was great
I'm not one of those people's like
Oscars are the end-all be-all but if
you're working in that industry they
kind of are for you and your career so I
know everybody's touched on it but
seeing the look on bong Joon Ho's face
when he won the Oscar for I believe it
was Best Screenplay
there's smile on his face puts a smile
on my face the spectrum of people after
they watched parasite it's like it's the
movie of the decade or it was great
whether or not it's the film of the
decade film of the year or just a great
movie that's a different conversation
most agree it's a solid move it's great
it's well-made it's engaging it's well
acted there's definitely worth watching
definitely worth buying on blu-ray right
so parasite have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more